hey guys it's benefits a cow from GE
tracker and in this video I'm gonna talk
to you guys about the suggested items
tool now with this tool you're gonna
find items that have a Lord trade
flowing and for that reason you should
start saving some slots at the grand
exchange be more long-term tight slips I
remember that is these flip should take
maybe a couple of hours to a couple of
days to take place and even if you're a
merchant that wants to sit at the grand
exchange and flip it as many items as
they possibly can in one hour you should
save us a lot or to fish some of these
items now I'm only gonna go over the
basics with this tool is showing you how
to use the filter settings so you can
start comparing items in the table and
then checking price margins in-game
looking at price graphs looking at trade
volume grass and then based on all that
knowledge that you have in front of you
start thinking out which item you're
gonna pick now you can see here I have a
screenshot of three items that I checked
in game for their price margins and then
later in this video I'll show you why I
picked one item as opposed to the other
items so let's get right into it alright
guys so this is what your suggested item
tools gonna look like and you can find
this tool under flip under and it's
gonna be the first link
now if you're a free user though you're
gonna notice that you're only gonna be
given five items every 10 minutes so
when you mess with these filter settings
up here you're gonna want to make the
best use of that and make sure you pick
a price range that works for you
however if you're a premium user you're
gonna be shown 50 items at any given
time and you're gonna refresh this table
as many times as you want now if I click
on the filter settings up here you're
gonna see a list of options to give this
table some input on what you want to see
now since we're only going over the
basics in this I only guys I only want
you guys to focus on the price minimum
and the price maximum now as an example
for this channel and you know what I'm
gonna be flipping for as an example for
you guys I only started off with 1.5
million because I feel like anyone can
save up to 1.5 million so even who
someone who's new can relate to this so
earlier using this tool I actually
flipped Sarah dolmens light you know
don't worry about this earlier I kind of
I don't know what happened but earlier I
flipped her Dilma's light and I bought
them for around 135 thousand each and I
sold them back for a hundred ninety
seven thousand eight you know starting
at about 1.5 million and then almost
getting back to point two million and
then right now I'm trying to flip
Carroll's crossbow but I'll get into
that later in this video okay so since I
only have around two million I'm gonna
put in here a hundred thousand 1 million
and what you notice is you can write
this in short you don't have to write
out the number in
which is good but you should keep in
mind you can't keep these blank so if
you just clear out the numbers for price
again thinking this table doesn't have
any value for it so it's just some
Christman it's not gonna like it so
you're not gonna be able to save it okay
so you have to give it up value but just
because you're even though you're giving
it a value though
anytime you login it's gonna save that
value so if you come in here and the
table doesn't show the price range that
you set it up all you'd have to do is
click on your filter settings and those
numbers will still be there so you just
have to click Save filter and then the
table refresh and show you the items
that you had saved before it will
actually show you a new list of items
but it'll save that number for that
price range and I'm just gonna be
clicking on this every now and then make
sure I don't log out okay so if you look
at this table here you're gonna be shown
a list of data for each item you know
their current offer price
the current selling price how much you
might be able to make you know the
return on investment you could make on
this how much is this trading per hour
and then the buy/sell ratio some items
have their GE limits listed but not all
of them do and if you like an item and
you want to keep an eye on one specific
item for a long period of time then you
can always favorite it and if you do
it'll start it'll turn into a blue star
for you and then you'll be able to find
your favorite items under your dashboard
but using this table if I wanted to find
the highest profit possible then I would
just click on this table right here now
the first time I click on it it's gonna
show me the least profitable highest
profitable items first no I don't want
that so I'm just going to pivot again
and it says show me the highest
profitable to least profitable now one
thing you'll notice is with with the
price range that I put at and because
these items have such a low transit
Volume I'm probably going to presented
with items that are more cosmetic you
know items that don't have a real big
use in the game it's not really a big
demand for it so I shouldn't expect to
see huge numbers here for the buying and
selling quantity now if I had more money
say I had 100 million and I wanted to
increase his price range I'd increases
price range to about 20 million and hit
enter
work with this table here and then then
it'd be shown a list of different items
that are also in that price range and
you're gonna be seeing at a higher value
more ppm like gear you know stuff that
has more of a demand and use and there's
whole concepts we can get into in terms
of you know long term investments with
updates and PBM gear and changes to the
game but we'll save that for another
video I just wanted to show you guys
that with this table depending upon how
much you have you're gonna be able to
make money easier the more you know and
the more you have okay and what you're
we're also going to notice is with a
higher valued item you're gonna see
these auto eyes being a lot smaller but
the profit is still gonna be huge so if
I went back to what I was previously - 1
million in order to make that two
hundred and fifty thousand or a hundred
thousand I'm gonna basically almost have
to double the price in that flip in
order to make something similar and in
order for that to happen I'm probably
gonna have to wait a while you know
have you seen item that has a 50 percent
or 40 percent ROI I'm more than likely
gonna have to wait a couple of days for
that item to flip so for that reason if
you want to flip those you cannot
prepare for that but personally for me
I'm not gonna choose those
but why don't we go over the sera Domas
light that I picked earlier and see why
I might have picked that okay so you're
gonna receive after you click on one of
these items in the table it's gonna show
you this it's gonna take you to that
specific items page and it's gonna give
you a little bit more information you
know the price graph and the trading
graph so it's gonna show you the average
price average offer price and the
average selling price and this is
showing you that right now it's it's
hitting its peak because the approximate
profit right now is negative so there's
a trend right now in the community where
people are paying too much and this
items will see a decrease pretty soon so
if you were gonna try and flip this you
would need to keep that in mind and
start putting the value much lower than
what is being shown right now but for
beginners if you saw a negative value I
would stay away from that but I can go
over that I can go over that concept in
a different video on how to capitalize
on downward trends like this it's not
always profitable but sometimes an item
is and with this item
this is very common so this would be an
item that I would profit off of this
kind of downward trend okay
so looking at the price craft you're
gonna notice that you're gonna have
different time frames here you can look
up at a day a week month quarter and up
to a year now one thing that's unique
about GE tracker is that we're the only
tool out there that shows the price
graph going back to a year so if there's
any yearly trends you're gonna spot them
and you're not gonna spot them anywhere
else and there are certainly items out
there that you're gonna see some of
these trends know well you might have
noticed with when I clicked on the
yearly and quarterly graph is there was
a dip that you didn't see previously you
wouldn't have seen this if you were
using any other tool and that's really
cool because you wouldn't have seen that
kind of trend but since this is a short
term flippin kind of video we want to
look more towards the week and day
timeframe now what you're gonna notice
with this item is during the weekend day
there's a huge fluctuation in price
between low and high and it's pretty
consistent so it which means I could
probably flip this all week long and
make a decent profit you know when I was
flipping this earlier I could I could
still be flipping it now but by the time
this is this video's release
I'm sure there's me none of you guys out
there flipping this so the profit
margins on that is probably gonna go
down or the for a while some probably
got to move on to something else
and that's why I've been focusing on
more fast faster flips which I'll get
over which I'll go over on this later on
so but with this price graph you're
gonna notice these fluctuations which is
a good thing if you want to have that
huge profit margin that I had but you're
gonna have to realize with these gaps
you're gonna probably have to wait
awhile and when you look at this
training this trade volume graph it's
just gonna further poop that because
you're gonna notice that only maybe 4 or
20 of these are being sold in any given
hour and it's gonna be on the lower end
it's gonna be more like 2 or 3 sold at
any given point in time so you're not
going to flip this very quickly so if
you do flip something like this you're
gonna want to keep that in mind and
maybe keep some other slots and have to
go in exchange for your faster flips and
this right here would be an example of
an example of a faster flip okay
so using this tool I found this earlier
and it was showing me about a 20k profit
margin
maybe it'll show it here I need to show
it back in the table so I can show you
guys if not oh yes right here okay so
earlier it was showing me 205 and about
so almost 20k profit per trade now what
I want you guys to pay attention to or
what I want you guys to know when you
guys are looking at this table is not to
take this information that base value
because that's wrong
because I see a lot of people when they
use this tool they think okay offer
price 209 maybe 210 to 216 and that's
what I'm gonna flip it for and that's
wrong
the markets dynamic and the markets
always changing and you should always be
pushing for profit margins you shouldn't
be looking at this data and thinking
this is exactly what it is in game
because it's not it's accurate and it's
gonna help you find items that are
profitable at that given point in time
but it's not gonna give you a pinpoint
exact data on what that is in the
trading port because there might be some
guy and game I already put in that item
up for sale that hasn't hasn't been
bought yet so it wouldn't be in this
data yet so for that reason you should
always check the price on profit margins
in game so if you look at this graph
you're gonna notice that it's more
flatlined it's more of like a pancake if
if you will if you want to flip items on
a quicker basis one little bit more
often like maybe a couple of hours maybe
you waited on this for two hours or
something like that this would be
something that you'd want to look for
you want to see something that's more
pancake like so noticing that this is
dipping down to 200,000 ish to 220,000
and then maybe a little bit more but
that's a little rare it looks like so it
looks like more like 230 to 220
210 230
okay so it actually looks like I got
this at a good price at a good time
because some of this is telling me that
this was me this was selling at 2:30
earlier today for the Carroll's crossbow
and I got it for 205 which is really
good because that means I could sell it
back or possibly Kinsella possibly back
for 235 K possibly let's see let's look
at the weekly basis doesn't look like it
goes above that so maybe maybe just 230
K is what I'll put it for so that's good
okay so as a short-term flipper that's
what you're gonna want to look for
you're gonna want to look for more of
those some pancake-like flips and what
you'll notice here is the OS buddy is
also giving me its own price in-game
okay so that could be telling me that I
should put this at a higher price
because if someone's impatient and
they're also uh knows buddy and they see
231 K I might I should probably put this
for you know 235 K you know I was just
gonna put this for a dirty K but after
seeing this I'm going to increase that
hopefully make more so
some hopefully I'm gonna go from a 2
million like investment to 2.3 million
almost 2.4 million investment which is
really good and those are the type of
flips that you guys want to be looking
for and for the examples that I showed
you guys earlier oh and this is our disc
or chat you guys don't know we have a
discord chat so if you guys have any
questions about items and games how to
flip or just want to talk about
runescape in general we have that here
and it's a really nice community and
there's no staff around to help you
there's always someone nice enough to
help you out these guys are really nice
and it's a really good community be a
part of so you should really join it but
for the examples okay for these examples
for the misdial staff I didn't pick this
item because that margin was rare that
margin was showing me on the graph that
it simply wasn't happening it happened
maybe once or twice a week
maybe in a day and that wasn't enough
for me to justify trying to buy tanner
and for the dragon axe I didn't buy this
one either
simply because the profit margin was too
small you know I didn't want to make
4,000 on an item and given that it's a
dragon axe people already know how much
this is worth you know it's already been
sold and bought so much that that price
isn't really gonna budge so there's
really not much there for me to go for
but the Carrows crossbow was like a nice
mix in between the two but also being a
nice quick flip so this this is probably
not gonna sell by the time this video is
over because trying to go for the higher
end of this but if this video is
released before I end up flipping this
is where they have to cut back on my my
laughs my losses here or still try and
prop it off of this hopefully oh yeah
so that's the tool here guys and you
guys have any questions any feedback you
know let me know in the score chat in
the comments you know this is my first
video ever creating any type of YouTube
content so if you guys have any
suggestions you know what you guys want
to see you guys want to see maybe an
hour of me flipping using a specific
tool maybe you guys want to see me just
flipping in general and you guys want to
talk about some context about contents
about long term flipping you know I
don't know you know whatever you guys
want me to talk about you know let me
know in the comments below you know
other than that
leave a like and a comment and you know
share this with your friends you know
good luck munching and then til next
time